this election year the choice is clear
one man stands ready to deliver change
we desperately need
a man I'm proud to call my friend
a man who will be the next president of
the United States Barack America
[Applause]
oh we should have known people we should
have known that was a long time ago
Barack America lordy lordy I'm Dave
America this is the Reuben report it's
December 12 2022. I'm in a good mood
this morning uh as far as I know I no
longer have coveted I've decided not to
test I'm playing with the kids again
it's all good and this past weekend I
went to see my all-time favorite singer
Frankie Valli how old is Frankie now I
think he's like 87 years old can you
check that he's about 87 years old he
gets out there it's not the original
Four Seasons anymore he's got his new
band I've seen him I've seen him a whole
bunch of times but I wanted to show you
one little 20 or 30 second clip from
this thing because he's doing all the
old hits Oh What a Night begging you
know all the stuff right who loves you
he's 88 years old Incredibles he's doing
all the hits he doesn't do much
interaction with the crowd at this age
you know he's just kind of getting out
there and they do their thing and that's
it but out of nowhere in the middle of
the concert he's like I don't want to
talk about politics and then he just
went on this political rant and I was
like oh God please Lord no I've had so
many of my heroes in life turn out to be
horrible human beings and and call me
racist and the rest of it I was like oh
God is he gonna suddenly come out he's
gonna be a lefty whack job
alas Frankie didn't let me down
[Music]
anybody in this room that couldn't be a
better president than what's going on
[Applause]
at the end there if you couldn't quite
hear it he said I was thinking of
running for president in the crowd
cheered that I'd rather have Frankie
Valli as president than Joe Biden and
I'm pretty sure he's more mentally aware
and he can still be on stage and he
didn't Shake in an imaginary person's
hand and he knew which way to walk off
and he did all the songs and all this
stuff so anyway it was just it was just
so absolutely refreshing look I don't
want politics brought into every concert
and you know every time you turn on a
comedy show or whatever it might be alas
this is the world we live in and every
now and again uh somebody doesn't
disappoint you and that was uh that was
a pretty sweet moment anyway we got a
big show for you today because uh all
hell's breaking loose uh the machine is
just coming after Elon Musk time and
time again hit peace after hit peace and
it's like maybe there's something else
going on here then what is just sort of
the obvious top layer of this thing
which is that a billionaire bought
Twitter could there be something else
that he's exposing that the machine now
is going all in on just trying to
absolutely destroy the guy and could
that be connected with all of the other
lies that we have been sold for so long
whether they're covid related or Russia
host hoax related or Jesse Smollett
related or anything else that the the
bias uh and the out of control
authoritarian I would also perhaps argue
even fascist activities of the left are
being exposed in real time and I'm not
just saying fascists just to say the
word but if you combine state and
government power
you get some fascism uh so we're going
to dive into what it's all about there's
there's a lot cooking at the moment uh
before we get to any of it let me talk
to you guys about bullying Max real
quick you know as inflation surpasses
highs not seen in 40 years the value of
the dollar is decreasing with every
passing day you're paying more at the
pump the grocery store for cars for
housing face it paper money is worth
less guys the time couldn't be any
better for my new sponsor bullion Max
bullion Max is direct to press direct to
Consumer precious metals retailer who
can help you diversify into gold and
silver it's a hedge against inflation
it's also security for your family in
times of Crisis and here's why I love
bullion max they're owned by veterans in
the precious metal space offers some of
the lowest prices on the internet and
they make it so easy to buy directly
from their website I wanted to help you
get started so I worked out a special
offer just for you get bullion Max's
silver starter kit at employee pricing
just go to booleanmax.com Dave the kid
includes five of the most desirable
silver products to invest in including
an American Eagle and soup Australian
kangaroo this offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com Dave and now back to me
okay so
let's dive right back into the Twitter
and as I always say you may not care
about Twitter but what happens on
Twitter cares about you so you got to
pay attention to it uh Elon Musk put
this one up over the weekend he's diving
in my pronouns are prosecute slash
fouchy uh yeah he is not happy and it
makes you think that perhaps as I've
been saying for a couple weeks now do
you think that Elon Musk might be
sitting on some major freaking
Bombshells related to what the
government had Twitter do when it came
to censoring people people simple humble
little YouTube hosts like me when they
tweeted honest things about covet and
then were suspended Etc you think he's
sitting on a treasure Trove of
information there you think he's
realizing uh what many of us have
realized and it's better late than ever
that fauci screwed up this entire thing
that while he was telling us to mask he
was telling friends not to mask while he
was calling for school closures he now
pretend ends he doesn't he never called
for school closures told us that the
vaccines work did we fund the gain of
function in Wuhan yes we did did it leak
from a lab it probably did et cetera Etc
anyway so Elon puts out that uh tweet
there and then just a random person by
the name of David Lee responded will
this be explained in a new Twitter files
part meaning this prosecute fauci will
is is there a drop related to fauci and
covet Elon says yes well then
Scott Kelly who is Mark Kelly's brother
Mark Kelly of course is the senator from
Arizona he's the guy he was the
incumbent senator who beat uh Blake
Masters he's an astronaut Democrat all
good his brother chimed in and wrote
this uh Elon please don't Mock and
promote hate towards already
marginalized and at risk of violence
members of the lgbtq plus Community they
are real people with real feelings
furthermore Dr fauci is a devoted public
servant whose sole motivation was saving
lives all right uh let's first do the
lgbtq stuff what the high hell is this
guy talking about there is literally no
evidence zero evidence period that Elon
Musk does not like gay people he doesn't
want people to be forced to use certain
pronouns we'll get to that in just a sec
I don't think he likes being bullied and
everything else but this he that the
idea that he's promoted hate against
anyone is in saying I said to my guys
right before the show started the irony
of Twitter right now is while the entire
machine and all of mainstream media and
the whole thing is telling you how much
hate there is on there and there's more
hate than ever and blah blah blah
my Twitter experience in the last couple
weeks has completely flipped because a
few weeks ago nobody was seeing my
tweets and I was barely getting any
responses and when I did get a response
it was usually somebody just saying
something awful to me now because people
are seeing my tweets again my feed is an
Endless Love Fest so I'm actually
getting the reverse I suppose or I
suspect they're not going to write a uh
an article about that in the New York
Times the awful amount of love being
shown to the right wing Twitter sphere
oh you got it uh okay so Elon responded
to Scott Kelly he wrote I strongly
disagree forcing your pronouns upon
others when they didn't ask and
implicitly ostracizing those who don't
is neither good nor kind to anyone yes
true as for fauci he lied to Congress
and funded gain of function research
that killed millions of people not
awesome in my opinion so all right let's
just put the gay thing aside in the
pronoun thing aside he's obviously
taking the right position on that you
you treat people with respect they'll
treat you with respect nobody should be
bullied or forced into this these
nonsensical when I get emails from
people who have their their pronouns in
their signature it's just like it's all
just ridiculous and awful and it's also
just symptomatic of society that has
done so well that is so fat on freedom
and prosperity and everything else that
you can have people uh you know
basically I want to be called this not
the other thing where I'm going to
destroy you anywho uh as for the second
part of that that fauci funded gain of
function research the nih-funded gain of
function research we know that we know
that they were doing it at the lab in
Wuhan we don't as far as I know have the
direct peace that will connect the two
dots of did we fund this thing and then
somehow did it literally like jump out
the door or did somebody walk out and
get bit by a monkey that then this that
the other thing okay we've all seen the
movies so like we don't have that uh but
fauci has been pushing propaganda all
along
I don't know that he's inherently evil
right and I don't even think that
matters and and the good intentions
matter and all of that stuff I I don't
think that fauci might get my gut
feeling would be
that fauci got into this job to do
horrible things but at some point along
the road as in now 75 year old you know
bureaucrat and that's what he is who
lasted several administrations he ended
up doing a lot of damage because he he
lied
where the purposes of apparently pushing
vaccines on everybody and he was four
lockdowns in all of these things and
it's all nonsense
and a guy like me who had or maybe even
has covered right now and I was
completely fine and I am unvaxed you
know the funny thing is when I was in
New York last week I was at a family
event tons of people there got covered
my parents got covered my sister got
covered my aunt my uncle my cousin all
got covered everyone's vaxed everyone
was Far sicker than me I'm in the middle
some of those people are older than me
and my parents but my sister's younger
than me my cousins younger than me I'm
the only one unvaxed and I was
completely fine I'm not saying that's
indicative of anything specifically
right but like there's something kind of
there so who knows what the hell is
going on here anyway fauci is still at
it with the propaganda and he simply is
not going to stop until he is held for
account of his actions you have to
remember he's the highest paid employee
of the federal government the guy makes
over four hundred thousand dollars a
year on top of all the money that you
have no doubt he has made in the market
because he knew what was going on like
you just know it like this is how the
swamp operates so what is Elon really
doing by going after fauci like to put
that tweet up prosecute fauci what's he
really doing there well you know he's
sitting on stuff he is sitting on stuff
that Twitter knows about what the
government forced people to whether the
government forced Twitter to take things
down or whatever was going on there how
do we know all this well it just still
continues the nonsense around covid two
and a half years later someone someone I
saw over the weekend put up a message
that we are a thousand days from 15 days
to flatten the curve isn't that
something where a thousand freaking days
huh well here's what's going on in the
world of covid uh Dr Jill Biden and she
is a doctor you have to mention that uh
she was with Ashish God talking about uh
getting vaccinated and uh it sounds to
me like she's sick actually the most
important thing you can do to prepare
for your holidays is to get your updated
covid vaccine
and if you get it now you'll be
protected in time for winter holiday
gatherings
okay first off it's not the most
important thing you can do to prepare
for the holiday you know what you could
do for prepare to prepare for the
holiday you could start thinking about
what you want to serve family think
about the menu you can start inviting
people over you could start putting
Christmas lights outside put a manure in
your window you could start doing some
of that stuff it is not important that
you do that and the idea that still at
this point they would tell you that the
vaccine is going to somehow save you is
insane but what else does fauci want he
really wants to vaccinate not just
children infants infants and I got two
infants in this house
little over that way four month old and
a two-month-old and fauci will not be
getting anywhere near my kids I've been
very clear about that fauci here's what
he wants to do with the kids and with
the holidays approaching we've had lots
of questions about safety of gathering
with friends and family especially if
loved ones haven't been vaccinated so
Lucy from Maine asks since we've been
vaccinated how dangerous is it to be
near our grandchildren they have not
been vaccinated Beyond what's required
in the schools right well vaccination
again is the answer so if you want to
protect your grandchildren and vice
versa even though the grandchildren are
not required to get vaccinated if they
are within the age which is now six
months or older I would encourage their
family so if you are the grandparents I
would encourage my child who is the
parent of my grandchildren to get their
children vaccinated
all right we're getting demonetized
today guys because he's just an evil
[ __ ] I I don't know what else to
say sorry no lunch for anybody today
guys that's it
he's just an evil freak that's what he
is the idea that he would be okay if you
believe for one second they have done
enough studies uh on six-month-olds
getting injected there is no freaking
way in high hell that my kids are
getting injected with that stuff okay I
don't know what the hell it is they
don't know what the hell it is and it's
not stopping covid as I just said
everyone that I was at a family event
with last week got coveted they're all
vaccinated the only one who didn't get
sick was me
and I somehow tested positive but I was
healthy it's all pure endless nonsense I
I just can't like I honestly cannot
imagine I cannot imagine
how someone could be watching fauci and
be like oh he's still relevant and
interesting and worthy of listening to
uh but we must hold these people
accountable and unfortunately we didn't
I mean if we learned One Thing by these
midterm elections Gretchen Whitmer in in
Michigan got reelected Kathy hochel in
New York got reelected Gavin Newsom in
California got reelected these people
seem to want more and the signal that
you send to authoritarians when you say
hey authoritarians oh you're you're
really taking care of me you're really
doing all these things so that I'm
locked in my house and I can't go to
work and you're destroying everything
but I guess I kind of like it because
perhaps I have some sort of other
existential problem that I should really
be thinking about instead then you vote
them back in and they will do it again
so in Los Angeles California Los Angeles
Public Health director Barbara Ferrer uh
I think we have video of her in just a
second we should have put up a picture
of this woman because she looks like
death and if you would like to get your
health advice from someone that looks
like death then I highly recommend you
listen to Barbara Ferrer anyway she
wants to bring back indoor masking it's
probably going to kick in next week
LA County will follow the CDC guidance
for communities designated at the high
Community level including Universal
indoor masking
I live in Florida
it's insane insane you know it's almost
one year to the day December 17th was
the day that we got here December 17th
what's today the 12th yeah we're right
there
um congratulations if you live in LA
like get the hell out or just like go go
down with the ship enough of these crazy
people as if it's not bad enough in LA
because of the covid maniacs and the
General State of misery and everything
else they got this new mayor okay so
they had Eric Garcetti and this guy was
absolutely terrible and homelessness
went crazy in drugs and crime and all
you guys got all the stuff right so they
have this terrible guy Garcetti uh then
what happens I mean this is what happens
with progressives always can you it's
horrible it's everything's terrible
there's homelessness everywhere
nothing's working crime is up and
everything's horrible what can we do can
we make it worse yes let's find someone
more far left can we find a crazier
leftist and that's what they did they
voted in this woman Karen bass here she
is being sworn in by Kamala and why is
Kamala laughing you decide according to
my best ability Madam mayor
[Applause]
do you solemnly swear
[Laughter]
what is wrong with these people
she's been injected with something
anyway back to fauci for a second uh
Chris Wallace who was on Fox then he
went to CNN plus and he just bounces
around and people like you got to kind
of say you like the guy I don't know
he's nothing great at this point anyway
he uh had fauci on this weekend and they
talked about lockdowns there was a study
that came out recently that said that 9
out of 10 people that are dying in this
country are over 65. looking back and I
understand that this has been a dynamic
situation it's changed over time
could we have been less restrictive
about schools and less restrictive about
closing down the economy and focused if
not from the very start earlier on on
the elderly you know in the absence of
vaccination that would have been very
difficult to do but right now that you
have the ability to vaccinate people you
can actually clearly be much more
liberal and open in what we're doing
which is where we we are really right
now complete nonsense he's a devil
worshiper I don't even know what to tell
you he's a lizard person devil worshiper
the vaccines don't work they don't stop
or transmission they don't stop you
getting coveted or giving covid or
anything else and yes why still a
thousand days after 15 days to flatten
the curve why still do we not generally
talk about health and sunshine and
getting fresh air and doing cardio why
do they never talk about all of the side
effects and all of that stuff okay you
guys get all that but I want to link
this to the Twitter situation because
the Liars are not going to continue are
not going to stop lying right so fauci
will not stop lying Kamala will not stop
cackling Biden will not stop poorly
reading off the prompt or whatever they
put in front of him the machine is all
in on that and what's happening now at
Twitter is that actual truth is able to
uh Express itself it's able to
disseminate because now Elon Musk is
just letting people back on to say what
they want and if you don't like it then
don't read it and it should be as simple
as that that's what that's what actual
free speech that's what the actual
exchange of ideas really is all about so
let's just combine uh the the faucian
covid insanity
to the lies because the only reason that
someone like fauci can Thrive is because
we he there's the whole system has been
set up in place so that if you lie as
long as you do it
to punish people as long as you do it in
service of the machine then you will
stick around that's how it works uh so
here is video back in 2018 there's a
million of these videos uh former and
disgraced CNN anchor Brian stelter who
got fired from CNN and now he's teaching
a media course at Harvard because that's
the most perfect example of how these
people fail up if you're part of the
machine uh here he is in 2018 with then
Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey asking if they
Shadow ban and of course I don't have to
tell you this we there we saw the whole
freaking Twitter file dump the other day
and covered it they do Shadow band Jack
even responded to me once saying that
they don't shadow man but they do shadow
man he also lied under oath to Ted Cruz
about it but here's a little bit more
the president called you out for shadow
Banning what is the truth around that
idea
so I think a lot of the in the the
statements behind the statement the
question behind the question is
um look Shadow Banning is a
very widely defined term there's not one
signal definition
um
so
the definition that we found that seems
to resonate with the most people is
um you know not amplifying particular
messages or if someone puts out a tweet
hiding that tweet from everyone without
that person who tweeted it knowing about
it so but the real question behind the
question is are we doing something
according to political ideology or
viewpoints and we are not
okay so it's a lie again you can lie to
Dave Rubin in a tweet when I ask him if
you should have been you can lie to
Brian stelter in an interview you can't
lie under oath to the Senate which is
basically what he did when Ted Cruz
asked him that very same question so he
was lying he was also playing and I and
I knew this when he responded to me a
couple years ago he was playing a
linguistic game around Shadow Banning
right because he is to his credit it is
true there is no official definition of
Shadow Banning to Shadow Banning mean
that nobody sees the Tweet or does it
mean that only some people see the suite
like there's ways that you can play
these little games so that you could say
we don't Shadow band because my
definition of Shadow band is different
than your definition of Shadow banana as
the Twitter files showed they didn't
actually call it Shadow Banning what'd
they call it VF it was called verifiable
uh what was it
yeah what was it verifiable we'll we'll
get it in a second uh anyway once the
the nonsense and the lies are exposed
these people uh disappear right that's
consistently what they do uh here's a
little more of what's going on with
Twitter from The Daily Mail Elon Musk on
Thursday evening confirmed that
conservatives were banned from Twitter
despite not violating any policies as
the latest installment of the Twitter
files showed the scale of the censorship
and visibility filtering there you go on
the social media platform musk singled
out yoel Roth the global head of trust
and safety who wrote in internal
messages that he wanted more creative
ways of censoring and muffling specific
accounts and content former head of
censorship at Twitter was perhaps not
entirely unbiased musk said accompanied
by a screenshot of a 2017 tweet in which
Roth said there were actual Nazis in the
White House okay so that's kind of
interesting so look there's a big pile
on happening on this guy Joel Rock who
was you know doing a lot of the trust
and safety stuff
I'm going to go out on a limb and say he
basically was just awoke leftist who was
kind of in over his head and then
decided that he could use his power uh
to silence people and he is now fired
and should be fired and Elon is of
course uh doing the right thing but
what's interesting about this is are we
going to the New York Times thing now
yeah so look at this so this is from Fox
News uh nobody's covering this in
mainstream media the Twitter file dump
right so ABC zero minutes CBS zero
minutes NBC zero minutes you need to
understand this because this is you know
as I said on Friday
I think what's happening is we're
basically splitting into two realities
and in some ways I think we're really
splitting into two internets
um and maybe that's how it's going to be
there's going to be one internet that I
think you and I will be part of and
there will be new tech companies
involved and there will be a basic
respect for freedom of speech and it's
going to be a little bit Messier and
sometimes people will say mean things
and you're going to get conflicting
information about things and then there
is going to be this very very hyper
controlled internet where it will be
official authorized sources and nobody
will question the narrative and that's
where all the the NPCs the non-playable
characters are because if you look pull
that image up one more time if you look
at that zero mentions ABC CBS and NBC
they did not feel the main networks did
not feel that a Twitter dump a file dump
where they are actually exposing the
fact that these people were censoring
major political voices not only Donald
Trump but they were actually censoring
people so that they could not get their
word out there do you think that maybe
that affected the election a little bit
is there are we even allowed to talk
about that but why can't they even show
that why can't ABC News because you know
there are meetings right so ABC News CBS
uh NBC they have meetings they're giant
corporations they have meeting what are
we going to cover on the on the news
tonight at 6 30. and they all look at
that story and they go well we really
can't talk about that because everything
he's revealing goes against all of the
nonsense that we do here all day long we
put Anthony fauci on to spread his
propaganda all day long we're the ones
that are calling half the country racist
and bigoted all the time and all of
those things so they can't have it so
that's what I'm saying these react I
don't think there's a way to Arbitrage
these two positions anymore I think
things are just going to continue to go
in different directions and I actually
think that's actually okay I really do
believe that here's a journalist by the
name of Ethan
rhombus definitely Greek I hope I didn't
butcher that too badly katsuru katsuro
around something like that uh he wrote
yep checked again nothing on New York
Times or Washington Post this morning
about Barry Weiss's reporting that
Twitter unequivocally muted and
blacklisted the voices of GOP political
candidates coveted doctors telling the
truth and influential conservatives yeah
and here he he went and this is a
screenshot so he's on the New York Times
website right there and the New York
Times did not cover it ironically the
New York Times has been doing stories
left and right I mean the scrolling goes
on and on here you got the point
um The New York Times has done plenty of
Stories on how the government should
look into Elon musk's other business and
how Elon Musk isn't doing enough about
child porn that's on Twitter even though
he's doing actually a ton right now and
for the last 10 years they haven't
written any stories about uh child porn
that was on Twitter I don't know why
they didn't care about it before Elon
Musk now he's actually doing something
about it he's been in he's been in
Twitter space his chats which is
basically like a live radio show talking
about what he's doing Forbes
which is another one that's ignoring all
the stuff they never once talked about
child porn until Elon took over it's
wild watching these people do what they
do it's absolutely wild but I want to go
back to the New York Times for just a
second because look you guys get the New
York Times is absolute trash you
remember they wrote I was on the
freaking cover of the New York Times a
couple years ago on a Sunday me Jordan
Peterson Thomas Soul Ben Shapiro Milton
Friedman about how we're leading people
to the alt-right like the whole place is
just absolute it's just horrific trash
but they're having their own problems
because uh not only are they just a
awful propaganda network but their
employees are on strike right now and I
wanted to show you this it's like a
minute video from Fox where they started
interviewing some of the New York Times
employees who are very upset at the New
York Times and you'd think that a place
a New York Times plays a good
Progressive organization you'd think
they'd be treating everybody great and
things would be going just just cheeky
over there but apparently that's not how
it's working out what are you guys on
strike about we've been at the
bargaining table for 20 months now the
company is consistently coming into the
bargaining table with proposals that are
insulting and unacceptable the New York
Times is making record profits and the
people who make the news need to share
in that it's a variety of issues but the
big things are we haven't had a raise in
over two years what are they not giving
you uh they're not giving a basic floor
wages of sixty five thousand dollars
I'll be honest I don't know the details
that that specifically we have been
working through the entire pandemic
without any salary increases at a time
of record inflation is this about coming
back to the office
um it's also about coming back to the
office of course we also want to make
sure that we are protecting people you
know we're still living through a
pandemic remote work is part of the
negotiation we find it ridiculous that
the company is maintaining this position
that it have the unilateral right to
call us back in five days a week I
thought the New York Times respected
Union so what happened there you'll have
to ask them that's an excellent question
I I would love an answer to that as well
excellent question we'd love to hear
what the management has to say about
that yeah it's a very good question we
thought the New York Times respected
unions too what happens to the New York
Times when you guys are on strike we'll
find out we have said we're not going to
write stories uh we have photo people we
have electricians other people in the
building who are not working today they
have to figure it out on their own I am
refusing to write I'm refusing to
respond to edits I imagine they're
having quite a hard time putting uh the
product the publication together the New
York Times can't run without the people
who run the New York Times
and management needs to know that if you
guys are all on strike who's going to
write the fake news
well we don't actually think that we
write fake news what an extraordinary
collection of whiny losers like how else
can you describe it these people they're
so shocked that that the New York Times
is hypocritical that the same paper that
pushes all the stories about unions and
how great unions are it doesn't want to
do it when it comes to its own people
and you can't believe it the New York
Times dares wants them to come back into
the office and these little children
pretending we're still in a in covid and
pandemic everything you all deserve
everything you can get and what's really
beautiful about that though what is it
that
create again I always say conservative
but what is it that creates a sane
person most people are liberals by
default right like you're a liberal or a
lefty by default because of the just
cultural norms in a country all of these
silly leftist clowns they're all being
mugged by reality right now they're
really they're suddenly going oh it's
not exactly as we think it is and I
would hope that any of them would then
learn that their ideas are wrong and the
ideas of the New York Times are wrong I
think the New York Times should fire all
them or they should all protest
endlessly and there'll be nobody to
write the fake news there'll be nobody
to write their crazy propaganda and like
these people they think they're so
important I'm not going to edit I'm not
going to write it's like you're never
gonna get another job you people are
lucky that anyone is willing to spend
any time with you ever and that's how I
feel about that uh let's continue
because the mainstream media has been
lying about everything for an extremely
long time you know that uh one of the
things they did of course was the hunter
Biden laptop a laptop story which is a
New York Post story well here's Trump
holding a copy of the New York Post this
is in May of 2020. this is after Trump
had been banned on Twitter and here he
is
no he wasn't banned on Twitter yet oh no
no no no sorry this is this is before he
was banned on Twitter good catch man
this is before he was banned on Twitter
but he was getting suspended every now
and again and people were realizing that
the people that support him suddenly
felt like they were being Shadow banned
and everything else so this is May of
2020 just to be clear holding a copy of
the New York Post and listen to who he's
calling out uh here's one this is our
this is the Arbiter this guy is the
Arbiter of what's supposed to go on
Twitter he's the one he thought that uh
he thought and he used CNN as a guide
CNN which is fake news he uses CNN as a
guide his name is yoel Roth and he's the
one that said that uh mail-in balloting
you look mail-in no fraud no fraud
really why don't you take a look all
over the country there's cases all over
the country that's not true so here here
excuse me I'm not finished so here's
your uh here's your man and that okay so
it's worth showing that because Donald
Trump to his credit he gets a lot of
things right way in advance they treat
him horribly for it and lie about him
and all of those things and then it
usually turns out to be true so this guy
yoel Rock who Elon Musk
fired who clearly I mean the guy was in
charge of trust and safety but clearly
was abusing his power and coordinating
it with the government I mean there are
internal slack emails from Twitter
people where he's talking about going to
meet with the FBI et cetera et cetera so
like this is serious stuff but there's
Trump getting it right on this YOLO Roth
guy and if only Twitter could have known
if only I don't know maybe YOLO Roth had
sent out some tweets implying that he
might not be unbiased do we have any
such tweets
oh look at us uh this is a tweet of his
from a couple years ago I'm just saying
we fly over those states that voted for
a racist Tangerine for a reason that was
retweeted then by Kirsty alley who just
passed away last week I'm very sad about
that uh Dear Mr yoel uh Roth uh Sawyer
comment I live in one of those flyover
states so did Mark Twain Amelia Earhart
the Wright brothers Henry Ford and
Thomas Edison to name a few you ignorant
uh c word we've already been demonetized
let's not get double demonetized
um but you see the point that this guy
was sending out these tweets calling
half the country racist do you think he
was the best person to be leading trust
and safety that that woman vijayagade
who was the woman that was the head
legal counsel at Twitter who has since
been fired remember when she was on Joe
Rogan with Tim Poole and she was so
obviously lying about absolutely
everything but these are the people they
left in charge or you look at Jack
Dorsey and it's like for some reason
people have this weird soft spot with
him because I don't know if it's because
he seems like he eats a lot of mushrooms
so people think he can't be like evil I
don't know that he's evil but if you're
in charge of the thing and everyone else
beneath you is doing evil things while
the buck stops with someone you're the
CEO so I think a lot of this is going to
come crashing down on him uh my friend
and former guest Vivek ramaswamy has
been making the rounds talking about
what's going on here with Twitter and
who is ultimately responsible for what
Twitter did silencing dissenting voices
etc etc and here he is talking about how
it's possible that these people are
going to be charged with fraud he knew
they were doing something wrong and they
lied about it and still hid it they
absolutely were engaged in Shadow
Banning they had the public belief that
some of this was just done by AI when in
fact it was done by actual human beings
right and to me that's not just doing
something wrong when you lie about it it
means you are culpable because it means
you knew you were doing something wrong
and you did it anyway at the highest
levels and Link legally speaking to me
that forms a new basis for a legal claim
of Consumer Fraud which is actually
telling consumers you're doing one thing
when in fact you're doing another
okay so that's an important piece what
he said there at the end that were they
actually engaging in Consumer Fraud you
know one of the things I was saying
years ago I mean you can watch videos
from 2017 when a whole bunch of us
started talking about censorship online
first was that if these are pro are
public companies so Twitter is now a
private company because Elon bought it
but it was a public company and Facebook
is a public company and Google is a
public company they have a fiduciary
duty to their shareholders to do the
right thing financially by the company
if it had come out that actually they
were Shadow Banning these people thus it
was not the best inch it was not in the
best interest of the company that's not
what people thought that they were in
essence buying what the shareholders
were buying then there's a huge problem
the board is in direct conflict with
what its duty is to the shareholders and
Jack and the other Executives they
answer to the board so there's a Litany
of problems here but he's right it's not
just that they were doing this stuff by
Ai and pretending they didn't know what
was happening they're all on the record
saying it wasn't happening at the exact
same time sometimes on the record when
they were talking to Congress or the
Senate so there is there is a lot of
stuff here that I the reason I think
this stuff is important guys
is because
if we can unfurl some of this stuff and
right now we have literally the richest
man in America enabling people to get
more honest information out there if we
can unfurl some of this stuff we won't
fall in these traps again the next time
the massive lies coming the massive lies
comes so let's tie it to the earlier
stuff the next time it's covid II or
monkey pox 9 or the cold the climate
meltdown or whatever we'll have some of
the tools to be like wait a minute wait
a minute you pulled this lie on us
before we've seen it all before we know
how you did it with censoring and
suspending and all of those things so
we're not going to fall for it again but
one of the things that the left is
incredibly good at and the Machine is
incredibly good at and the corporate
press is good at and Democrat
politicians are really good at is they
will Gaslight you all the way down you
will be finding out the truth you will
have the receipts in front of your face
and they will tell you you do not see
what you see here is Eric swallow Eric
swallows is an absolute embarrassment as
a congressman he's a he's a congressman
from uh Northern Cali
here he is this is about a year and a
half ago talking about how no there's no
such thing as Shadow Banning and it's
just a big conservative conspiracy
theory saying that you think no bill is
really necessary at all when it comes to
antitrust Tech regulation I don't think
these bills address what most Americans
are concerned with it and by the way
I'll just add
Republicans some Republicans are
supporting this legislation and my
concern is they're not supporting this
because Republicans all of a sudden care
about antitrust they're doing it for the
same reason Ron DeSantis is going after
Disney they're doing it to be punitive
Republicans have this you know warped
perception that Google and Facebook and
others are Shadow Banning them when you
look at like the best performing uh
pages on Facebook and it's all
conservative voices but they again in
their warped minds they think that
they're being affected by big Tech
that's that's their interest here
okay so he's a liar and he's just a
[ __ ]
um saying that uh the traffic on
Facebook let's say daily wire gets all
the traffic on Facebook that doesn't
mean that they're not con uh censoring
conservatives a maybe the traffic for
daily wire and Ben Shapiro is supposed
to be way higher than it is but it
doesn't mean they didn't delete a
thousand accounts of other people that
were beneath him you know what I mean
that were lesser known or anything like
that we now know that they were Shadow
Banning without question what's also
interesting about that was it has
nothing to do with the question he was
asked he went out of his way to say that
these Republicans think that they're uh
you know that it's a conspiracy theory
and blah blah blah Shadow Banning and
all this stuff
um he also goes after Ron DeSantis and
Disney like and Rhonda said this
absolutely did the right thing with
Disney and also won by uh 20 points so
the proof is in the pudding right here
in Florida uh here's just a little
throwaway video of uh Eric swalwell
farting the Chinese flag taxpayer
dollars to ask the ukrainians to help
them cheat an election and the complaint
that I've heard from Republicans all
last week
as far as I know that was unedited
there's that one more time one more time
taxpayer dollars to ask the ukrainians
to help them cheat an election and the
complaint that I've heard from
Republicans okay so while Eric swalwell
is a is a liar and a fraud and a
complete buffoon I mean he's really just
like if you have that short list of some
of the worst of the worst that are in
politics he's right there
um he was lying about that and we know
he was lying about that and this is what
they do with everything they lie about
everything so here is Karin Jean-Pierre
our black lesbian press secretary uh
denying that the administration worked
with Twitter to censor posts I suspect
she's going to regret this one because
Elon is sitting on a treasure Trove of
stuff but here she is Twitter uh Elon
Musk this week fired uh the former FBI
general counsel Jim Baker who was
serving as a top Twitter lawyer musk
alleges that he may have been involved
with countermanding his attempts at
transparency and I was wondering if
anyone in the Biden Administration was
in touch with Baker either regarding
modern decisions that predicts called
political censorship or regarding his
transparency efforts recently so it's up
to private companies to make these types
of decisions we were not involved I can
say that we were not in all right it's
absolutely incredible the levels and
this is what I mean by gaslighting the
levels of their lives are crazy this is
the same woman who last week and the guy
that she works were Joe Biden saying you
know Elon Musk is doing hate speech and
we're going to have to look into him and
look into his other companies now here
she is saying oh well he's a he's a
private company he can do whatever you
want she's also implying that they've
had nothing to do with any of this so
you need to understand how crazy this
story is
a lawyer at the FBI and we know that the
FBI was talking to Twitter about what
posts to take down right we have the
emails that show that now the slack and
internal documents an FBI lawyer James
Baker was also the lawyer in charge of
vetting this stuff at Twitter once Elon
Musk found that out he immediately fired
him so there is a Smoking Gun here
somewhere and also you don't even need
to do much research on The Smoking Gun
because this Administration has admitted
repeatedly that they go out of their way
to talk to social media companies about
posts that they can take down
jensaki in July 2021 it's a it's an
oldie but it's a goodie
the administration been in touch with
any of these companies and are there any
actions that the federal government can
take to ensure their cooperation because
we've seen from the start there's not a
lot of action of these platforms sure uh
well first we are in regular touch with
these social media platforms uh and
those engagements typically happen
through members of our senior staff but
also members of our covid-19 team given
as Dr Murthy conveyed this is a big
issue of misinformation specifically on
the pandemic in terms of actions Alex
said we have taken or we're working to
take I should say from the federal
government we've increased
disinformation research and tracking
within the surgeon general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
Facebook uh that's man it's wild guys I
know no matter how many times you see
this stuff it's like they lie about
everything but here's Karin jump here
just a couple days ago saying that oh no
we don't have anything to do with any of
this and then there's sake a year ago
saying yes we do flag posts senior what
did she say senior staff and the coven
folks they contact social media about
misinformation they were doing it they
told us that they were doing it and now
they're pretending that they didn't do
it despite the fact that Elon has all
the docs now so do you see why they want
to destroy this guy do you see why they
want to make sure that people can't see
the truth so then and then how the whole
machine works so the administration lies
about something they admit it with sake
that they deny it a year and a half
later with Karin Jean-Pierre then
Twitter dumps these docs right so Elon
goes to Matt taibi Barry Weiss they
unleash these documents they go around
mainstream media so then mainstream
media ABC NBC CBS does not cover it at
all on their 6 30 p.m evening broadcast
which is supposed to be the Nightly News
that would at least one day back in the
day get you caught up on what you need
to know but now they're by Omission they
default are not allowing you to catch up
on reality and then as we showed you
earlier the New York Times doesn't even
cover it so a certain amount of people
will never be able to see anything true
and then we wonder why so many people
are crazy right because these people
have been gas lit into Oblivion and why
have they because doing the right thing
is a threat is a threat to them if if
enough people
had belief in themselves if enough
people could honestly assess what's
going on here and not be forced into
doing things but come to choices by
their own conclusions by their own logic
and reasoning we wouldn't need these
people that much and the whole structure
wouldn't exist that's a problem for them
Jordan Peterson he's got rid of 75 of
people and Twitter is still working with
record traffic right exactly and so I
think he will and apparently
he's also
put the boots to the people who are
track trafficking and child
exploitation already incredible right no
kidding no kidding in incredible in two
ways incredible that he did it but even
more incredible that he could do it that
fast and that it hadn't been done
isn't that the point nobody cared about
the freaking child porn issue on Twitter
until three weeks ago and suddenly
there's too much child porn on Twitter
because Elon has it and he's actually
doing something about it things are
changing right in front of our face
there is a chance that that
superstructure that exists that has
confused so many people that more and
more people can get out of it but
it will the grip us right and then
somebody said something about slipping
through fingers right wasn't there
something star system something and
speaking of which I've made a Star Wars
reference on the show in a while it's me
Monday over at the Reuben report locals
Community I was a little heavy-handed in
my video meme today I think what do you
think
but let's take a look
[Music]
she's tall she's tall that's all I meant
it's a joke people it's a joke oh Lord a
couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com Lori says is
Elon above being bought off given the
information he likely has I mean he is
literally the richest man in the world
so I cannot imagine a situation that
they could buy him off like you want two
of those super Yachts like I don't know
what they could buy him off but everyone
has pressures right like in some way you
know if he goes out there and they keep
saying all these lies about him and then
when he goes to restaurants he's getting
the evil eye the stink eye
if his kids if they can turn his kids
against him like everyone has familial
pressures everyone has their own
internal pressure so I don't think the
pressure is going to come to him
financially I think even if they go
after his businesses and try to destroy
some of their some of his businesses I
think he would actually keep forging
forward like it seems to me and and I've
I've never met the guy I would like to
meet the guy obviously uh he did not
have to do this this is the exact same
thing that I was saying two months ago
or even five months ago when he first
started talking about Twitter think
about it the guy's building Rockets to
send us to Mars he's working on
neurolink which will combine you know
it's basically like transhumanism you
may not like it but he's doing all of
these really interesting future Tech
things uh and he did not have to do this
but I think what he realized along the
way was if we don't live in a world that
is roughly based in the truth which is
what's happening because of mainstream
media and the Democrats and the and the
entire political establishment if we
don't live in a world that that is
approximate the truth then it won't
matter whether we get to Mars or not it
won't matter what we do in the future so
I think he just said I'm going to throw
all in on this money we're going to buy
this freaking thing and we're going to
destroy the mainstream media and we're
going to try to get something a little
bit closer to truth and look at the way
these people freak out freak out John
Brennan former CIA we should have shown
the Tweet former CIA director John
Brennan he put out a tweet that Elon is
creating more hate and blah blah blah
and it's like John Brennan you're one of
the 51 intelligence guys that said that
the hunter Biden laptop was Russian
disinformation do you think maybe you're
going after Elon because he knows
something about what you guys all did
what the FBI did related to that like
it's all there guys the pieces are all
freaking right there what do I keep
telling you it's like a puzzle but you
don't have the front of the box right so
you're looking at all the puzzle pieces
you're putting it together and it's
starting you're starting to get the
image it's all coming together but you
just don't know that perfect thing Elon
has the cover of the box
that's where we're at right now that's
really what I think is going on right
here uh the Valencia says we have come
to the conclusion that we live in
parallel societies one that is
manufactured by Hollywood big Tech and
big government and one that is the rest
of us that awareness has made life so
much more sane yes I love that comment
that that is it
because once you accept that if you
accept it and you accept that a certain
amount of people are going down that
route and that maybe you can't save them
or help them or whatever but that's it
just is right you may not like it but it
just is then you can live your life
hopefully closer to the truth and and
not so dependent on those things and
you'll be able to see through their
nonsense and everything else and and
hopefully move to a place that's a
little more in line with your values and
and everything else like
that's it Joe Shepard says God bless
space daddy the truth needed to be told
yeah he's doing it he doesn't have to do
this that's the point guys he did not
have to put his butt on the line like
think about it if you it's six months
ago
if you said the name Elon Musk he was
loved by all the people that hate him
right now what does that tell you what
does that tell you and again there is no
evidence that more misinformation is
shared on Twitter right now there was a
crazy amount of misinformation usually
chaired by the supposed reputable
sources on Twitter before Elon there is
no evidence that there's more hate on
Twitter as I said I can only give you my
own example I'm getting way more love
because people are actually seeing my
stuff it's a whole b s
but again this isn't just about Twitter
Twitter is where the stuff happens and
then it gets to the real world so look
at the end guys freedom is not free Elon
is miles ahead and and above the
walksters right you know that he's put 3
000 satellites into space to build
starlink right so he could give internet
to people all over the globe right it's
like man
he's trying and and just because he's
rich and it lives a life that none of us
myself included that none of us could
even remotely imagine what it's like to
have that kind of wealth and wealth and
that kind of influence and that kind of
literally like I can just pick up my
phone and put a put one emoji in Twitter
and all hell breaks loose
but he's trying so we got to try
alongside him that's what I think about
that rumble.com Ruben report if you have
not subscribed already if you want to
play along during the show of
reubenreport.locals.com and we didn't
talk much about Joe Biden today so let's
just leave you with a couple of his
gaffes and I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
and because of our when I restored
national monuments and bears ears and
the grand staircase escalated in Utah
France was our first outlaw
first country to fly the American flag
after a revolution and Frank hosted the
first diplomatic post you think I'm
joking I'm telling you if I hear more
about the navajos than I hear about me
from the spirit of Marcus Lafayette
Georgia
I'm going to Georgia today to help
Senator Warren not to Georgia we're
going to help Senator work that I'm
doing a major fundraise up in Boston
Mr President when will you need a new
Congressional leadership
you're as the most unusual questions
when I get to Washington
[Music]
when will you get your annual physical
Mr President
[Music]